huh
look familiar this is the newest iPhone
this is the iPhone se it looks familiar
because it's the iPhone 5s body with all
the same features from the iPhone 6s so
it's this four year old flagship on the
outside and an eight month old flagship
on the inside and with this phone Apple
is basically answering the call for a
small flagship smartphone all the
high-end phones these days are big
phones do a lot screens got bigger and I
see in the comments all the time like
people talking about it on Twitter
what's the best small smartphone you can
get that doesn't make any compromises
will be cool to see more of those well
this phone is definitely small so it
looks like it's kind of trying to fill
those shoes so yeah it really is the
iPhone 5 and 5s body and all its
rectangular chamfered glory the 5s was
my first iPhone ever so I kind of liked
this squarish design it's definitely
easier to hold with those flat sides
then the round iPhones we have now I
still would have liked to have seen a
new design though for a brand new
compact phone in 2016 instead of a
recycled one but this is what we got so
the only way you could tell you have an
iPhone se and not an iPhone 5 is the
rose gold color or that little SE badge
on the back which apparently stands for
special edition that's it otherwise it
looks exactly the same unless you add
any skin or case to it of course I'll
link this one below but when I first got
the se out the box I've been using you
know big phones for the past few years
so seeing a tiny phone that just gets
swallowed up in my hands was like nope
no way no way I could use this phone
every day and do all the same stuff that
I'm used to doing on a bigger screen but
it actually turned out to be not that
bad thanks to the high-end specs and now
I feel like I want to see more high-end
smaller Android phones too first of all
a smaller phone makes it easier
especially for people with small hands
to reach all four corners of the display
and that's important to be able to do
that without adjusting your grip it's
comfortable so it's great for all those
top left corner buttons in iOS and then
the smaller phone is just generally
easier to handle it's less phone in the
pocket less in the hand when you're on a
call it's also a little bit lighter I
mean I just kind of started getting used
to it like I got you
two bigger phones but there are
definitely downsides though the display
is the biggest one or I guess the
smallest one this is still the four inch
Retina display from the iPhone 5 so 11
36 by 640 and when your sub 720p you can
never quite match the viewing experience
or the gaming experience or anything of
a phone with a big display and
front-facing speakers no matter how good
the performance is but I'm happy to
report that performance is not a problem
at all the iPhone se like I mentioned
has most of the same features from the
newest iPhone so including the specs so
you get an A 9 ship and 2 gigabytes of
RAM for a low res display so basically
performance is a breeze here everything
is smooth multitasking is great that's
what you would expect and the camera
upgrade is also from the iPhone 6s so a
new 12 megapixel sensor and a slightly
smaller aperture has this taking very
similar photos and 4k videos to the
iPhone 6s now there's no optical image
stabilization but everything else is on
point the autofocus is super quick
there's a quick shutter that you used to
from other iPhones
I'll go right ahead and say this is the
best camera in a small smartphone so
that's got that going for it and the
front-facing camera unfortunately didn't
get the same upgrade treatments so
you're getting a pretty weak 1.2
megapixel shooter here it's not awful
but sorry selfie people and there's
other little things that just set it
back a little bit like it has touch ID
but it's the older first gen touch ID so
it feels just a little bit slower and
there's no forced touch pressure
sensitivity again from the newer iPhones
so no force touching shortcuts and stuff
like live photos uses a long press
instead now I think again if Apple had
designed a new small iPhone for 2016
they'd have both of those things they'd
have the new touch ID and force touch
but again since they recycle the old
body there's not quite enough room for
that and there you have it it's pretty
much everything you need to know about
using an iPhone se the one thing that
surprised me actually was battery life
it is a small phone and it has have a
small 1642 milliamp hour battery but the
life is actually very good and I guess
I'd attribute that to the a9 chip
everything else fell right in line where
I expect it it's just a really freaking
small phone so for 400 bucks should you
buy it uh it's not for everyone
that's for sure plus you're only getting
16 gigabytes at that price and I'd
pretty much never tell anyone to buy a
16 gig phone so for 500 or 600 bucks
you'd have to really want a small phone
after using it for a while especially
for reach ability I kind of get the
desire for smaller phones not saying I
could personally do it forever she's not
my thing but I get it thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you guys the
next one peace